let me begin by thanking CFR for
sponsoring these world-class researchers
here and in the rest of the room and
elsewhere the three centers Amy mule and
vector and this great workshop I also
want to give a long overdue thanks to
Miele for funding me in 1985 when I came
to Toronto to work as a postdoc way way
back when
that's me let me begin as usual by
asking the panelists to say a few words
about themselves and about their
research and maybe go in this order hi
I'm Aldo reservoir I have joined
université laval as an assistant
professor in July and an affiliated with
Miele I've been working at the
intersection of computer science and the
health since above 10 years in fact was
an when I was a master student I used to
develop computer simulation software to
help decision makers in public health to
evaluate and compare different
prevention and treatment strategies that
could be applied to a population and
eventually as I was doing this I thought
I mean it's nice to evaluate expert
strategies but what if we could find an
optimal strategy for given a specific
population and so I started drifting
towards machine learning more
specifically towards reinforcement
learning which is now my field of
research with an important focus on the
multi-armed bandit setting and yeah this
is my like my theoretical work and I
like to tackle challenges that are
motivated by applications such as design
of experiments like what we find in
clinical trials thank you yeah hello
everybody my name is Dennis stock and I
have a background in computer science
and medicine and I work as a
neuroscientist for almost 10 years now
the general theme of the work of my team
is to embrace the emerging large
in the brain sciences which is since
recently only kind of a big data science
we try to find kind of innovative
modeling solutions to revisit some of
these classical questions like sex
differences in the brain exist or not
and then translate these new findings
back into the application domain so and
this bridging of medicine and computer
science previously was manifested in
working as faculty at the Faculty of
Medicine in Germany but also at in
earlier Seikaly in France and I'm happy
since November first
to now be a faculty at McGill's Faculty
of Medicine as well as associate member
of Mira hi my name is Anna Goldenberg I
am a professor yeah so I am actually
senior scientist at the Children's
Hospital in Toronto I'm also an
associate professor in the computer
science department and I'm a vector
faculty and associate research director
health
that's vector my field of interest
spends everything that's possible around
healthcare probably including RL most
recently but we started thinking about
the complex diseases from the biological
standpoint so I've done a lot of work
and kind of data integration to
understand the complexity of human
diseases but most recently I've been
working on trying to figure out how to
build machine learning models that we
can implement in healthcare back at the
hospital and towards that extent I'm
co-chairing and the ion medicine
initiative for the pediatric hospital
where we are really trying to understand
what will it take to implement these
systems and trying to be reasonable
about that hello my name is Tyler Bell
I'm a professor in Electrical and
Computer Engineering at McGill
University and
associate member of miele my research is
really at the intersection between
machine learning computer vision and
medical image analysis so my background
is in computer vision in terms of grad
school and but my research program has
been focused a lot on probabilistic
methods in medical image analysis for
many many years with a lot of
applications within the domains of
neurology and neurosurgery so this
includes probabilistic graphical models
Bayesian methods and recently a lot of
interest in Bayesian deep learning my
research focus has really been on trying
to develop methods that have clinical
impact I've worked for many years in the
area of building probabilistic graphical
models and deep learning models for
things like segmenting and detecting
lesions and tumors from patient brain
images patients with multiple sclerosis
and other neurodegenerative diseases and
brain tumors recently I've worked a lot
on uncertainty in deep learning so
that's very important if we want to
integrate deep learning models in the
clinic so I'm looking at models of
uncertainty and also propagating
uncertainty along different inference
tasks which is very common medical image
analysis and recently I've been becoming
very much more excited about these new
projects where I'm looking at deep
learning models for predicting future
disease progression and and also
determining responders to treatment and
and looking at temporal evolution of
disease and trying to determine sort of
metrics to to determine if the clinical
trial is working or not working and
moving towards precision medicine based
at least partially on medical images
like MRI hi my name is Irina riche I
just recently joined Mila and University
of Montreal as associate professor I was
previously at IBM TJ Watson in Yorktown
New York for many years and I would work
there on both sides of the ying-yang
kind of relationship between
neuroscience and artificial intelligence
the direction from artificial
intelligence to neuroscience basically
focused on applying machine learning
statistical analysis tools to detect
discover statistical biomarkers of
different mental disorders such as
schizophrenia joint work with Russ which
gave quite a bit of traction recently
also chronic pain
Coquina addiction and pretty much many
other disorders also including not
psychiatric but rather neurological like
Huntington disease and so on and so
forth they are more recently we were
moving from analysis of brain imaging
data such as functional Moriah eg
towards beyond the scanner data such as
text speech wearable devices video all
kind of relatively cheap data you can
collect about person which can be
informative about person mental state
and this is really I think exciting area
of research because it's much more
practical you don't have to put person
and a scanner you can potentially design
an app your personal guardian angel or
personal psychiatrist a personal
therapist or just a friend call it
whatever see movie her but you get the
idea so it can track your signals track
your mental states and perhaps call for
help when needed tell a joke when the
person is falling to depression
applications are mania so it's just kind
of one of the areas of AI for neuro and
psychiatry that I'm currently focused on
there are many other topics in the
opposite direction which involve
focusing on core AI and going along the
direction from current narrow AI as we
understand that AI that can be trained
on fixed data set to do really well on
particular tasks like play go or
translate from language to language or
detective
in diagnosed something from MRI imaging
towards human-level AI which is a quite
a big leap but I believe that on the way
from narrow to human level it would be
useful to go through broad AI by broad
AI I and other people mean essentially
continual lifelong learning making a
systems learn continually to perform
different tasks so you would have
versatile AI that can one day learn how
to play go next day how to translate
from English to French which I still
have to work on and then can diagnose
stuff from images and so on and so forth
so this is kind of AI focus where
neuroscience hopefully can provide
various inspirations such as stability
versus plasticity knowledge we know and
so on and so forth
thank you okay of montrose Lizzie gonna
know that have a good week so my name is
Mallory I come from a background of
medical physics I worked in research in
radiotherapy departments basically since
my graduate studies and really now I'm
moving towards a public university in
the computer science department but
still affiliated to the hospital and now
I'll be affiliated with Mina Soto during
my graduate studies basically the work
that we've done was concentrated on
precision oncology building predictive
models to find the best treatment for
each individual individual patient right
right treatment at the right time
basically so I've been building
predictive models in cancer when the
treatment decision comes there's many
variables to consider basically there's
imaging that can inform us but there's
genomics demographics text reports
there's many different types of
information that can come into play I've
been focusing on medical imaging most of
all during my graduate studies given
that normally most tumors are more
aggressiveness normally tend to have a
mortar genius patterns and virginity
inside the tumor intro tomorrow into
virginity see we can capture that with
medical with different quantitative
image analysis I've been building models
with that to predict tumor
aggressiveness basically and now I'm
going towards more integrating different
types of omics data together so the
medical imaging radio mix so genomics
all that together and also considering
that the whole flow of data source in in
the electronic health record system
basically to build predictive models
thank you very much what a wonderful
diverse group of people of good skill
sets first question I want to pose is
what is the most exciting advance in a
machine of applying machine to
healthcare over the last few years
there's been a lot of exciting is here
but what do you think is the number one
thing well by definition my answer will
be very subjective because I only can
judge from what I know about but I find
that extremely exciting this hold
raising Wickfield of computational
psychiatry yes that you know well about
and particularly as I mentioned
computational psychiatry beyond the
scanner so text analysis for example of
interviews with psychiatric patients
that can reveal few years in advance
which of the prodromal patients can
actually develop psychotic episode and
doing that just from transcribe text was
close to hundred percent accuracy is
quite exciting I would say there are
many many other examples of text and
speech analysis which can very
accurately detect and/or predict
development of certain mental conditions
anything from addiction to depression
and so on so forth and I think this is a
quickly growing field and this is I
think very useful and very exciting to
me I agree I'm just gonna say actually
data so in the brain sciences at least
if you look at psychiatry in Iran
neurology neurosurgery the reality is
that even consorted datasets that were
acquired over over years by Confederated
efforts you rarely exceed data from a
thousand people so that's just the
reality it's just very hard to acquire
these types of data and we are very far
away from internet scale data in these
pockets so and but since we have always
virtual data sets from always more
people like genetics brain imaging and
so on much vaster spaces of the
landscape of mourning towards actually
become accessible for the first place
in the first place so and I think this
is a very important kind of watershed
event other comments I don't know I
think it's hard to come up with just one
right for you two it's one top because
we I mean the reason why we are here I
guess because we are excitable a lot of
different things I'm kind of very
excited by the direction of the
counterfactual modeling in healthcare
there's been a lot more of it so
counterfactual modeling causality is a
bit less advanced I would say in in that
space but there has started being some
real modeling advances in that space and
we really need it in healthcare even
though we can do well with predictive
modeling there are other types of
questions that are harder to answer
there are some very interesting so I'll
just list the top twenty and then but I
think there are some really nice methods
about irregularly sampled and missing
data so there are models that are
starting to really model real data as
opposed to you know making an assumption
that everything is measured regularly
like ironmans and that or that the
difference between the time points where
they are measured are not important I'm
going to stop for now other is you get
more chances
comments personally I'm pretty excited
with what natural language processing
can do with medical text reports what I
was during my postdoctoral training in
San Francisco worked with a team and we
basically assessed survivorship
long-term survivors or short-term
survivors with just medical notes and it
was pretty interesting to see that what
can be done and that usually post
analysis after building those empty
models you can go back and see which
words are important survivorship for
different types of cancer there's
different mutations that can come out
but there's a soul also social factors
that came out of those post analyses
that I found very interesting like we
can imagine depression may be an
important word that came out of those
analysis depression divorce things like
that so I think it's really important
really interesting NLP it would make
complex reports well I would say that
all the work that has been done in
representation learning in general
allowing to work with data that is
complex which is a kind of data that we
have to work with in the field of health
care has been helping a lot so yeah I
just want to say for me it's taken a
while for deep learning to enter the
field of medical image analysis for a
variety of reasons one of which is the
data but for a variety of other reasons
so we're starting to see deep learning
models enter medical image analysis and
we're starting to understand that the
problems of medical image analysis are
very different than computer vision and
so things that worked in computer vision
work for some applications and medical
imaging but there are many of them were
they don't so this provides an
opportunity for people and machine
learning to start to say hey I maybe
I'll collaborate with you've got all
this interesting data and now we have
advances in machine learning that are
spawned by medical imaging so you see in
our conferences that we go to you know I
typically go to Makai and middle and
those much more machine learning but
innovative machine learning where you
have these collaborations where people
are starting to go okay you have this
other data set most data sets are small
let's look into transfer learning domain
adaptation metal learning and all of
these
really interesting sort of machine
learning models that need adaptation
need innovation and so it's actually
exciting in that with these two fields
working together I think that now we can
have innovations in in both theoretical
models but also actually have impact in
healthcare it's interesting I'm working
on all these different projects it's
nice to hear reinforcement for my things
I'm working on next question so how is
machine learning at AI in general
changing the practice of healthcare or
is it first but I think the answer is
yes
I don't think it's changing the practice
much yet I think there is a potential
that that's out there there are several
systems that have been implemented in in
practice I think as machine learners we
don't necessarily anticipate the kind of
things that will bring the algorithms
down right we focus on them on a method
and methodology try to perfect that but
things that can change or the underlying
electronic medical record system where
they've recorded or stopped collecting
whatever data they were collecting
before and now collecting something else
entirely and somehow they don't notify
in advance the algorithms other people
that would care to have to rebuild stuff
so I think there's a lot of there's a
lot of hope on both sides I think the
way that it will change is prevention
I'm hoping that machine learnings role
in healthcare is to prevent a lot of
critical events or forecasts predict to
not let critical events or even disease
try to change the disease trajectory for
the better
intervention will will play a great role
in this space but we're just starting on
that path I think ok I just want to add
that yes if we work in our own little
silos we will not make impact and
clinical here but I think that for those
people that are working on machine
learning models if we can have
collaborations with clinicians and R in
real clinical problems as we develop our
methods we will be able to have impact
and so that's the key it's not to do you
know sort of half machine learning
models and then translate them I think
we need to work together so a happy
Canadian story is that we have worked my
group has worked in collaboration with
machine learning researchers like join
up recap and so on at Mila and also with
people at the Montreal Neurological
Institute and clinicians as well as
industry and medical industry has been
instrumental and what we've been working
on so we work we have collaborations
with a company called neuron or X they
develop software analysis tools for the
pharmaceutical industry for pretty much
all ms drugs that have are developed in
the world and so with data that they
have provided us with manual
segmentations of lesions we have
developed techniques and worked with
them through insert through an insert
see Rd worked regularly with them to
develop new probabilistic models
graphical models in fact and then deep
learning models to be able to detect
lesions which are endpoints for clinical
trials and our software system or have
been embedded into the software analysis
pipeline and narek so pretty much not
only does that speed up their process
but pretty much all the multiple
sclerosis new multiple sclerosis drugs
out there in the world have been
developed using software that we have
developed so my perspective is that
there's a lot of excitement for and and
kind of neat for precision medicine so
stakeholders policymakers funding
agencies they really want to invest into
this but when I read these these grants
and the papers I'm wondering so how are
we exactly gonna go from group averages
where we give medication that is good
for people on average to kind of
different granularity where medical
decision-making is really based on a
single person's profile so and I think
what would be a useful reflection in
this direction is to really identify
milestones on the way there
so what could actually be actionable and
possible that say in the space of three
to five years because now there's a lot
of funding in this direction but if you
have nothing to show in five years from
now like we need to identify some
low-hanging fruits if you will and to
keep the funding coming they have been
some deployed systems but not that many
okay so again I can only speak from my
own experience and what I've kind of
learned so far I I would say that
probably machine learning is changing
healthcare already not just in the
future well I would say both
there are various studies in machine
learning applications to healthcare
which probably only going to be adopted
in the future or may just paves the way
to the future for example functional MRI
analysis I'm not sure it's very likely
to become widely adopted and medical
practice ever it's a good tool for like
academic research but you need more
practical sensors that can change
medical practice on the other hand
machine learning applications to imaging
that achieve like superhuman accuracy on
MRI and there is other types of
measurements I think they are being
already practical and as Anna mentioned
I actually we just want to second this
opinion there trend towards prevention I
think it's an important one and I think
machine learning really can help there
and solidity helping one example is a
project we can have about to start with
collaborators from medical school
instead of doing some more invasive
testing for example of liver you can try
to see if you can accurately detect
certain disorders from just simple
sonogram that's much much cheaper much
easier
and if you can use sophisticated enough
machine learning to be accurate with
diagnosis you can do early prevention
and that's very practical yeah and I
think there are many examples where
application of machine learning and
imaging does help already but there are
many examples where there is much more
work to be done we're not done I agree
with it but I agree also with the the
the statement that said that it's not
changing routine clinical practice as
much as it should
I think AI is going fast AI metas the
development of those metas is going
faster than us that then us getting
access to the data basically
personally I feel like I've been
overfitting since 2011 no we analyzed so
I think we need to get better at
analyzing historical data that is
already in our hospitals getting access
to that so that we can then learn how to
build strong models that can have an
impact right now before thinking of
getting access to new data that will
come in to reinforce what we've learned
so let's get a data first well on top of
this I would add that I don't think that
machine learning is going to change
health by replacing the medical experts
more like providing them with companions
and helping them by digesting
informations that the medical experts
cannot process themselves yeah I think
that's an important point like a better
microscope thank you
we've already touched on some of these
but the next question is what is the
biggest challenges now we're very touch
about some of the issues but can maybe
elaborate observational data limit
amount to data educating our colleagues
yeah well thank you for almost providing
an answer so don't question it makes our
job much easier so all I have to do is
just to elaborate on that particular
topic but yes I think improving
communication across different fields is
always
tough thing to do and more needs to be
done and we just had a few weeks ago
actually another conference Maine
Montreal AI and neuroscience conference
at the University of Montreal I think so
the fourth year in a row and this was a
question for the panel how do we design
new programs for students who are in
medical school and psychology and
psychiatry in neuroscience and students
in computer science how do we kind of
connect them better because they need to
not only speak the same language they
need to have kind of common set of
skills common set of knowledge how do we
do that it's a tough question but what I
suggested there and I guess I will just
repeat it here I think it's a job of
their professors working at the
intersection of multiple fields to
design new courses that will be
specifically tailored for kind of
cross-disciplinary research so you only
teach to medical students to students in
psychiatry and psychology department
that part of mass and machine learning
that actually going to be useful for
them so they not get bored and they will
not ask questions like why they are
learning that because I think it's very
difficult to learn anything if you don't
have a good ends of the question why
you're doing that and grade is not
really a very motivating question I mean
answer the same thing for computer
scientists I think there is so much to
learn from other disciplines from
biology from neuroscience from
psychology psychiatry from physics from
philosophy because people have been
thinking about intelligence and what
does it mean and how mind works mind and
brain for at least a few thousands of
years in multiple disciplines and oh by
the way I didn't mention art and
literature so it's a quite an
interdisciplinary area and yet computer
scientist seems to be
kind of a little bit tunnel vision
sometimes I don't want to offend anyone
and I'm also talking about myself so I'm
just kind of right now starting to
explore interdisciplinary topics but I
think that people in machine learning
AI and computer science in general would
really benefit from new courses which
are interdisciplinary and they address
from different perspectives the
questions that computer scientists ask
could your volunteers who are going to
develop the courses I know yeah so I
fully agree with this and I would kind
of even say I think it's a science
sociological issue or an education issue
and I mean it's hard enough to go
through five years of computer science
or like five six years of medicine and
but then the question is how do you
actually identify people for like
interdisciplinary programs as you
suggest like how old us how do we know
that somebody who just comes out of
school can adopt a thought style of
biology is a thought style of computer
science or probabilistic thinking and
statistics we need like very careful
admission procedures to do this on top
and above and beyond redesigning these
curricula which is also hard because we
need to cut something out and I think
it's it's not exactly clear how to
reconcile all these things I don't think
it's a problem we don't really have to
get more selective I think people coming
to program they in any case starting
almost from scratch so I think the main
prerequisite will be a passion about the
subject and then it's a job of a
professor to teach well okay other
comments
so so I think there are immediate
challenges and then there are the
long-term challenges the education I
would say is a long-term challenge and
in Canada it's fortunately changing they
know how long it'll take but I'm sitting
and ozma right there we are sitting on a
the task force for the Royal College of
Physicians and Surgeons where they're
trying to change the curriculum for the
clinicians to incorporate digital
awareness we've been trying to define it
a little bit better but basically it's
to me it means that the doctors will
start understanding uncertainty a little
better that would help but I think the
shorter term challenges are definitely
data there is access to data right now
for broadly is is not it's not good it's
not there at all and we're talking about
generalizable models we're talking about
well I'm built building something it'll
work at my hospital work at another
hospital we have no idea because there
is no real path path to to try it in any
other place and you know the GTEs and
whatever that all of the bureaucratic
stuff that we are now engaged in it
takes months of all of my students none
of my students have patients I frankly
don't have Croatians both types of
patients right so there is yeah there is
and we are trying we are trying to make
it better doctor we are working on the
new data trust strategy but much more
needs to be done and globally to to to
provide that data access I think it's
one of the the biggest impediments to
making it much more impactful in Alberta
we do a very stupid access to various
data sets but they tend to be
observational data not RCT data which is
a notice that challenges but because of
the lack of data
you have especially medical imaging
these challenges sort of like cable yeah
for medical imaging so we have you know
the brats and all kinds of interesting
challenges in association with our
conferences and these challenges are
very helpful because people don't have
data so a lot of people try to win these
challenges and so I think one of the
biggest things that we have to worry
about is is to remember to design our
metrics in such a way that they have
clinical impact so a lot of the times
people have these challenges and then
they use traditional computer vision
metrics and everyone's fighting to win
the challenge and sometimes the metrics
are not in line with any clinical need
and so we have a whole bunch of people
in the field working really hard on
problems that may not ever be important
or of interest in a real clinical domain
so I think there's a responsibility to
to focus the challenges on the metrics
of interest to a specific clinical task
and to make sure that it's in line with
that task yeah I actually completely
agree with that and to continue and
somewhat kind of change the direction
that and also to answer the problem
raised by Anna so in one hand yes we
need to continue working on getting more
data but on the other hand we can also
try to work with what we've got and the
question of working with relatively
small data actually it's kind of well
you could say plagued the new imaging
field for a long time and perhaps other
medical fields but it doesn't mean that
there is nothing we can do first of all
we have to be very creative and
open-minded about machine learning
methodologies that we use for example if
particular methodology is very data
hungry
it doesn't mean I'll have to use it you
probably know what I am hinting at
actually he completely agrees with that
basically you use what works and you
combine it with Prior and I think one
clear way to deal with scarce data issue
sometimes if there is nothing else you
could do is to use prior which means you
need to work with
expert in the domain and try to
understand better what's known in the
field and you try to encode it as prior
into your models and sometimes priors as
simple as good old sparsity l1 can
actually help you feed a model with
eighty thousand variables say voxels in
the morale MRI and about forty subjects
and it will generalize and you do not
use deep learning you use sparse
regression and that's okay so basically
in medical field I think it depends yeah
you need to have your priorities
straight you want to solve the problem
or you want to have indexed nibs paper
you need to choose just finish on the
data problem very importantly we'll need
to get be better at having access to our
own data in our own Hospital first to be
able to analyze historical data and we
need to think start thinking now about
how will you will combine the data from
the different institutions distributed
learning networks actually will keep the
data in the hospitals basically it's got
a stay McGill is gonna stand for in pmh
but will we need to already build deep
learning capacities distributed learning
capacities to build models with many
different hospitals together the
theoretical foundations of learning in
deep learning exist obviously but the
capacities of research environments to
do distributed learning and to
collaborate together to build models
with by keeping the data and everyone's
hospitals is not there yet and I think
we have to start working on this now
well these are challenges for building
the models but if we want to have a real
impact we need to make sure that the
models can make their way from our
computers to the field like to the yeah
to where they need to be applied and to
do that we need infrastructures to make
sure that they can be deployed safely
that if those models keep evolving and
they keep eating more and more data that
this is never going to lead to a model
that
we thought was safe in the beginning but
because it ingested something weird now
it's broken and it's gonna diverge and
become very bad and I think before we
have those tools that can make sure that
a model keeps evolving safely and that
we understand why it is making some
decisions and we have a way to yeah to
ensure that if it is going to make to do
something really bad that we can catch
it before it happens and it's going to
be really hard to convince people to
deploy those tools okay well we're three
more questions but I guess I don't have
to ask them but maybe very quickly how
many people are actually working with
medical doctors right now so again two
people in the audience who are thinking
working in medicine that's a pretty good
indication of how to make progress and
become a co-chair so I'm gonna change
now to get questions to the audience we
should have the mics more centrally
located shouldn't we
great panel thank you very much for
sharing your wisdom with us my question
is about evaluation of course we develop
our algorithms on observational data
sets most likely and then there's a
challenge of evaluating of course the
doctors and the healthcare system won't
allow us to go implement our shining
algorithm on sight and effect real
patients so we gotta come up with some
some way to evaluate it in order to give
them some proofs that it will work on
real people so I would like I would
appreciate your comments and the
evaluation thank you so I think it's not
difficult to a lot of times to simulate
what would happen in clinical practice
right you just prospectively divide your
training and test that into the test net
which is which is prospective come in in
the past right so this is what we do we
do this all the time we for predictive
models especially we we have a cohort or
whatever set of medical records and we
just train it and whatever it was you
know some time ago and predict on
something more recent and I think a
bigger question and in what you are
asking it's not just that we build a
model we evaluate it but it's more about
which question we were answering in the
first place and it seems that even
clinicians with who I work with when
they come to us and they ask a question
and I say okay well would you implement
if we solve this question to some extent
would you implement it in practice and I
said well no and I say okay which which
question should we be solving so that it
would actually have an impact on
clinical practice and they change the
question and I think it's very very
important to be aware of that up front
that even clinical questions the people
who are clinicians when they talk to
researchers and the questions they're
interested from my research perspective
are very different to the
in clinical practice I would like to
emphasize very briefly I think they're
very different notions of validation in
different communities of data analysis
so the machinery has trained tests and
so on perspective but what they call a
lot of sample validation is not
necessarily this exact same notion and
genetics for example and classical
statistics may also have some Daivari
diverging notions so I think it's
important to be aware of this in the
first place and then as a practical way
forward I think the machining community
has kind of set a good example and can
serve as a role model because the early
established reference data sets like
analyst and so on the law to to compare
against a standard and I think the
medical community could really profit
from this director let me a quick
comment about the earlier question I
think party issue was observational
versus RCT data that you may have never
seen any examples of applying this
medication to this class of patients so
I think that was the main thrust of
question but your answers are also
talking about validation which is very
very relevant this could be fine yes
just quick comment about metrics and so
on we implicitly assume that most of
machine learning again is happening in
the classical statistical learning
setting of having a data set and
training a Moodle and testing that model
so it's all fixed there is no temporal
aspect and in practice again depends
which medical practice but say I'm
talking about say automated generation
of dialogue and applications to therapy
for example depression recently had that
reply paper out I mean accepted but
anyway just one example there are many
others it's very difficult to evaluate
the quality of machine learning output
immediately it's really if you think
about its reinforcement learning problem
reward is very ill-defined
not immediate because the outcome of
treatment is hard to judge it may not
happen immediately and yet you have to
generate dialogue on the spot
so I think it's not always even possible
to wait for the practitioners in the
field to tell you what the right metric
is because they don't always know
themself you may need to define help
them define it it just like by analogy
with totally other field like good old
times when Steve Jobs was saying that
don't ask customers what they want you
design it you show to them and they will
like it
same thing to what you were saying again
just to reinforce eyes that it's
important while we develop our methods
that we have continuous feedback from
the clinicians and the end-users so
again this could be clinicians or it
could also be companies that are willing
to deploy this and they often are more
strict in terms of errors and and
because they want to sell products so in
the medical industry so it's important
we met with our clinician every day
every month and students have to present
to the point that clinicians were saying
we'll wait a minute show me that loss
function again you know they were
becoming much more familiar with with
machine learning and we were becoming
familiar with their needs and okay I
just want to comment on the ICT aspect
of this so there is a current
understanding in a lot of kind of
machine learning for healthcare among
the people who are implementing it is
that our city is not going to be the way
to go for evaluating this models what we
are thinking of now again in a
predictive modeling setting is that you
start with silent trials first you do
the retrospective on the already
existent data then we do this this kind
of silent trial where the model can run
in the background to whatever extent it
can and it will be recorded to what the
output of the model is and in parallel a
clinician will be recording similar type
of outcome whatever was agreed upon and
then the comparison will be evaluated
prospectively but without effective
clinical practice so the subsystem that
was implemented Hopkins they did this
a system that was implemented at Duke
they did this at Stanford they are doing
the same thing so this is this is one of
the ways kind of a natural progression
of what happens now and after the silent
trial they actually implement a little
practice good conversation later two
more people I guess who is next
I'll go Alex on Douglas Lee and the
co-founder of imagine board member at
the millah I know we've talked a lot
about the explain ability or interpret
ability today I want to know a little
bit more about your interests in those
fields and maybe differentiate if you
think there will be some difference
between explain ability from a
theoretical perspective through the
regulatory agencies and maybe to the
doctor that only have like few seconds
or a second to assess whether or not the
machine tells the truth and maybe a
subsection to that what happened when
it's not in a medical images or other
type of data how can you provide
explained ability nice easy question
okay so we're working a lot on
uncertainty for those reasons we are
working on models that will tell the
clinician I have confidence for example
that there's a lesion here or this is
the tumor boundary I don't and there are
ways to evaluate that this is still
ongoing research so I think that it is
in fact important in terms of giving the
clinician that information if you meant
also interpretability which is a
different than I guess explained ability
we're also and I think as a field we're
starting to really look at
interpretability as an important issue
for example when you have diseases that
are not well understood and you can get
and then you can predict something for
example this person will survive you
know certain amount of months or the
disease will progress and then you would
like to open up the black box so there's
quite a bit of new research coming out
saying okay what was the network looking
at when it made that prediction and not
just when it made that prediction but
when it made it with confidence
and so there's a lot of interest in that
because then you can go back to the
clinician and say hey over the
population it seems the deep learning
model kept looking at these areas and
then people can work together to
understand disease evolution a lot more
but again this is a work this is very
recent research and I think that's where
also we need the machine learning
community to weigh in I mean it's very
tough question very far from having an
answer but I think it's an interesting
fun fact to consider that even if it
take like a linear model generalized
linear model that we know and love and
used in evidence-based medicine in the
training century if you add enough input
variables it's easy to argue that this
is also losing its interoperability at
some point in the last case that arena
mentioned for example and the high noise
scenario high correlated in a scenario
interpret abilities even gone in the
linear model regime so and then I think
it kind of for me personally becomes
kind of a semantic question again I
think we probably have to relax or alter
our notion of interpretability
or explain ability that we want to
impose on these models and I think
practically right now for me the
question is is if you have a complicated
deep nerve with multiple layers and you
perturb an input variable C do you still
get the same prediction accuracy and
then you go through all the input
Orioles if you kind of Disney the output
or if you use things like sharp line
whatever to kind of get linear
approximations to the body of this thing
of course that does not tell you exactly
exhaustively what that system did but
the question is is that perhaps a
sufficient practically useful notion of
explained ability that is sufficient for
what stakeholders and policymakers want
I think that's a useful question you can
always ask a question of how interpret
ball is the Christians in true
description another let's exercise maybe
one more comment more people one more
comment and other people I just I just
wanted to say that we actually did a
survey of clinicians
about what they would like to see in the
model and we have that paper in our car
if you are interested but it was very
interesting to us that different
clinicians at different stages of their
practice they wanted different things so
for example junior clinicians wanted the
validation that what what they have
decided is kind of the right thing to do
the older clinicians could not care less
if the system identified the same thing
they said I already know it this is
boring why you wasted my time they said
what we want to know is that if the
system disagrees and should provide
evidence to why I disagreed and again I
completely agree that one of the one of
the things that we started looking at
was okay so how would it act in
different situations the same as
training you know the complicated
machines that they're using for MRI
right now they don't understand exactly
how these machines work and the physics
behind them but this is this is
something that they actually did and so
we started building counterfactual
models to to show to try to explain why
the system made certain decisions and I
think that that went a lot better and I
want to mention a paper by Hannah
Wallach without by her group it's a big
group of people that shows that people
within models that are simpler they tend
to trust them too much so much when they
use these models they they're able to
kind of predict what this model would do
but at the end of the day when the model
makes an error
they are blind to it as well because
they trust it too much and that using
oversimplified models is actually
dangerous in practice maybe we should
yeah very patient perhaps we may be
going back to the issue with data the
quantity of data was discussed but what
about data sharing
so in healthcare applications we have
things like patient confidentiality and
it's not like other applications where
it's pictures of trees and cars and so
on so we're dealing with patient
information and what I find is that
a lot of institutions they have their
own data sets but there's not that much
data sharing so that we can compare
models using the same data set so how is
that to be dealt with maybe two quick
comments I just want to reinforce eyes
the point of I think we can overcome
that with spirited learning if we get
let the data at each one Despero we
don't will not have to share it
basically but we will learn by sending
the training applications from one
hospital to the other I think this is
very important and if I can also jump to
the question previous question about
evaluation maybe we should do
distributed learning applications like
this training from to each other just be
tall by keeping it there but then also I
don't know with three ten twenty hundred
hospitals I don't know we need to find
that sweet spot first of all because
that because patients are different in
USA and in Europe we all so what's that
sweet spot will it find it and I think
in any case we will always need to
fine-tune one model to a local
population or local hospital
it's also worth being aware of issues
like batch effects covariate shift and
domain drift on top of every type of
privacy issues I mean having worked in
the medical system for a number of years
I would not expect that there's a
massive culture shift in the next five
years and every medical doctor is happy
to share all the data that was very hard
to acquire I think that's very hard and
at the same time there are also
reasonable ethical questions there's a
sensitive information and we just need a
very strong regulation around those so I
think kind of work around like aggregate
statistics per site this is becoming a
standard in genetics at these core
regression 3 nature genetics papers of
2015 this is really taking off
nobody needs to share the original data
decentralized model fitting is taking
off so I think these solutions are
workarounds we need to expand on those
because I think we can't expect
boundless data
sharing the sensitive patient data I
think that's unreasonable to ask
although it is interesting that in the
genetics community things like
microarray data was all University
shared but that's but maybe that's no
patient my ability hey I just filing my
claim I'll go stop at this point I just
want to comment that I a completely
agree that the future is probably behind
the federated learning and but we are in
one of these projects now it's
incredibly intensive in terms of
resources because the infrastructure is
different in different places so it's us
and three other hospitals in the US and
they don't have the same infrastructure
so it's very intense on people it's
intense on like building infrastructures
and we need a clinician and the machine
learning person and both places to make
sure that they install things properly
and it's just I think it was brought up
before that infrastructure and building
that up is going to really enable maybe
one more thing I'm a quick add I'm
looking for a post-doctorate just
survival prediction
[Applause]